I set myself out with an interesting
challenge I wanted to see if I could
learn a dance that I saw on tick tock in
exactly one hour for those of you who
know me I am NOT a dancer I don't have a
dance background I'm not exactly
coordinated with my body legs arms or
general sense of self but I wanted to
see if I could do it
lots of people dance why can't I I saw
this tutorial by the name of someone and
I saw this tutorial by someone by the
name of Sammy Stead's on tick-tock there
was a little footwork tutorial
it seemed manageable it seemed tough but
he looked cool and I want to look cool
so I thought I could try this it was a
lot harder than I thought it was gonna
be I spent the first like 5 minutes just
watching just looking at the feet just
trying to understand what the hell was
happening with those titties and just
trying to mimic it as best I could and I
didn't get it but eventually I started
to breakdown the movements because
everything was clear and concise so all
I had to do was replicate it eventually
my legs would get a brain of their own
and they would figure it out I just had
to build to it so about 5 minutes in I
started working with a metronome I
started doing it at 60 bpm if I could do
it that slow then I can slowly build it
up every 10 BPM to get to the point
where I was actually to the tempo of
this song so I started 60 nailed it
perfect in every way I'm the best
feeling great 70 doin fine everything's
going according to plan I get to about
80 or so and I start to sweat I'm not
foreign to physical activity but I did
not realize how intense dancing was
going to be apparently if you flail your
body around enough you start to sweat so
every so often I would take a break
drink some water I would look at the
tutorial again make sure I was still on
it make sure I was still in it make sure
I wasn't creating some stupid movement
or my brain was farting out my ass just
I wanted to make sure that I actually
got it 90 100 110 120 120 is actually an
interesting one because that is the
tempo of the song but it is exactly half
the speed of the movement because the
movement is every eighth note
so that was an important one I kind of
hang on that one a bit and once I start
to get the speed of it I start jumping
up more and more and more
eventually climbing the 140 150 160 180
I got up to 200 beats per minute now
this is way faster than most songs are
but it's getting close to the actual
footwork and once I got to this point I
was starting to get real sweaty starting
to get real tired I was hitting about 30
minutes in the challenge but I felt like
I could manage it and then I realized
something
I realized that I was an idiot
I was doing it wrong because I I was
looking at the tutorial as being a
breakdown of the exact movements on the
exact beats but I've been practicing it
wrong
because in between the first few Criss
crosses there's no extra beat and there
it's cross stand cross right in pigeon
toe I knew it from the very beginning
once I realized my keys here and once I
got another glass of water I started to
get down to the Nitty Gritty because I
realized I had it basically the moves
were in muscle memory after 45 minutes
of trying and all that was left was just
repetition doing it over and over and
over again until I got it right boom
over over over and over again again one
more time keep going and it was funny
because the best ones I did were not
towards the end because towards the end
I was getting tired I was running my
Apple watch I showed it through the
screen a couple times my heart rate was
getting up to like 140 150 that's not
like the max max it could go but just
for trying to dance that's a lot of work
it was intense work you can see towards
the end my shirt is just getting soaked
with sweat I had my air conditioner
blasting max I was still overheating and
I'm a sweaty man I'm I get sweaty like
nobody's business but this was just this
was hard but I did get one glorious
beautiful
maybe not beautiful one glorious for me
attempt
and then I did it you know it's weird
after I didn't even realize I did it
because I didn't know what I looked like
until I saw the footage afterwards so I
had it in my mind because I didn't feel
like I was doing it very well but at
that point I just stuck to the rhythm
and I stuck to the repetition that I
thought okay I'm just gonna go to the
end of the timer and you can see that
when I get to the end of the timer I'm
just like alright screw it I'm out okay
good I did it finally Challenge over I'm
gonna go rest so I didn't even celebrate
because I didn't know that I did it at
all I had no idea what I looked like
like I have my camera up and I can see
it but when I was doing it I couldn't
look at myself in there because it would
throw me off so I just had to kind of
like Deadeye forward just kind of like
like just trying to concentrate so hard
I I don't look elegant in any way I want
to say that very clear I don't look
elegant my hands are doing a weird
flailing kicky thing but I did it in an
hour I am NOT a dancer I'm moderately
physically inclined but I am NOT a
dancer and I did it pretty well not
perfect definitely not perfect I'm not
saying I did it perfect because there's
dancers that make that [ __ ] look easy
and for some dancers that [ __ ] is easy
but I did it and I'm pretty proud of
myself so I set myself challenge I met
the challenge or at least I completed it
and I'm pretty happy with the results I
really have nothing else to say besides
that I I wanted to see if I could do
something and then I executed on the
plan and to be perfectly honest I feel
great about it it's something that I
would never ordinarily do but because I
saw it and I thought to myself maybe I
could do that myself
I now have pushed myself in the
direction of a skill that I have never
ever tried and I think that's pretty
cool
so if you want to see the the dancing
question I'll link Sami Stead's
tick-tock down below my own tick-tock is
down there I've started posting videos
there for marches on us and various
other crap that I find
if you want to follow me there toss me a
follow and just thanks for watching and
if you ever find something that you want
to do as a challenge to yourself don't
limit yourself go for it you might be
surprised with what you can do so anyway
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye